Thanks to Brilliant for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Go to Brilliant.org/microcosmos to learn how
you can take your STEM skills to the next
level this year!
Every living thing on this planet has water
in them.
Some may have more than others.
And some, like our desiccated tardigrade tuns,
may be able to survive long periods of time
without water.
But while those tardigrades may be alive,
they’re not quite living.
They’re taking a very protective nap, and
they’ll wake up only when water reappears in their life.
Water’s chemical structure is the basis
of life itself.
It shapes the interactions of biological molecules,
maintains the shape and structure of cells,
and drives reactions that power our entire
world.
And so, inside each of us, is an ocean.
And that…is why we pee.
Getting rid of waste is a complicated, messy
business to untangle, and boiling it all down
to a simple matter of pooping and peeing is
doing a disservice to the variety of organismal
junk around the world.
But we are just a humble YouTube channel who
has made one episode about how microbes poop.
And so now, it feels necessary to give equal
due to how they pee.
The goal, whether solid or liquid, is the
same: removal.
There are things in a body that must come
out.
But we cannot just wantonly dump things out.
That would be like sweeping any small item
in your house into a trash bag.
Sure, you get rid of some dust, but you’re
also potentially, throwing your wedding ring
into the dumpster.
In our bodies, we turn to kidneys to filter
out toxins and ammonia waste while reabsorbing metabolites.
What doesn’t get reabsorbed gets released
as urine.
But even simpler organisms need to be able
to regulate the water and metabolites inside them.
For one, water is a physical thing: it takes
up space and creates pressure inside a cell,
which is good...up until a point..
And once you get past that point, organisms
can end up bursting, like this poor microbe here.
And aside from the terrifying thought that
you could water yourself into bursting, there’s
the matter of maintaining the right balance
of life-sustaining molecules and getting rid of waste.
So parameciums and some other single-celled
eukaryotes rely on a set of organelles called
the contractile vacuole complex that are connected
to the outside through a pore.
The contractile vacuoles go through cycles
of filling and expelling.
As the vacuole fills up with fluid from inside
the organism, the pore closes up--keeping
everything inside the vacuole.
And when that’s done, the pore opens back
up.
You know, for the peeing.
So there are simple and effective methods
on the one end, and the complex organs on the other.
So, what comes in the middle?
Well, let’s take a look at this Asplanchna.
It looks weird, even for a rotifer.
And at around half a millimeter long, it’s
on the large size for what we normally see.
But it’s still a microscopic metazoan, which
means that unlike our single-celled eukaryote
friends, its body has organs.
Some of these organs seem roughly familiar,
like the Asplanchna’s stomach.
And the space around those organs is not empty.
It’s full of fluid, giving the rotifer something
to monitor and regulate for the sake of its own survival.
To do that, the Asplanchna and other simple
multicellular organisms like it rely on a
structure called the protonephridium, which
begins--oddly enough—at the end: with a
set of hollow cells called terminal organs.
In Asplanchna or other similar animals like
this Polyarthra, those terminal organs are
referred to as flame cells because of the
flickering movement inside them created by bundles of cilia.
Some organisms replace those cilia with flagella,
and their terminal organs are called solenocytes instead.
The Asplanchna’s flame cells draw in fluids,
acting as an initial filter that blocks the
larger molecules from passing through.
The cells use their cilia to send the fluid
down a coiled tube.
But at that point, there still might be some
important small molecules that the organism
could use in that mixture, like certain sugars
or amino acids.
And so as the fluid travels through the tube,
those molecules get selectively reabsorbed
into the rotifer.
What remains in the protonephridium is the
urine, which gets collected in the bladder,
drained into the cloaca, and then released
into the world.
A fun sidetone: cloacas act as a sort of multi-purpose
opening.
In the case of the rotifer, yes, it is used
for peeing.
It’s also used for giving birth.
So maybe you’re swimming in rotifer pee,
or maybe you’re swimming in rotifer babies.
Whichever one it is, it all came from the
same place.
As we mentioned, other organisms have protonephridia
as well, including flatworms.
Some segmented worms, or annelids, also have
a protonephridium, while others have a metanephridium.
The principle is the same: they take in fluid,
and then modify it to reabsorb what’s necessary
for the organism and remove what isn’t.
But the metanephridia connect directly to
the worm’s cavity through a ciliated funnel.
The remarkable thing about waste is that,
like water, we all have to deal with it.
It is every bit as much a part of life as
the living itself is, proof that our bodies
have done something, consumed something, made
something.
The only thing more remarkable is that even
when the basic principles of waste management
stay the same, the end results can look so
different.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Brilliant for supporting
this video.
Sure, we might’ve spent the last several
minutes talking to you about bodily fluids,
but with Brilliant, you can actually learn
about the physics of how toilets flush after
you put those fluids into them.
In the course Physics of the Everyday, you’ll
Investigate everyday physics, from household
objects to weather patterns.
Brilliant has courses about science, engineering,
computer science and math, and the courses
are designed to be hands-on with interactive
quizzes and guided problems with explanations.
You can access the Daily Challenges for free,
but if you sign up to become a Premium member,
you’ll get access to the entire archive.
And Brilliant courses are now available offline
using their iOS and Android app.
So if you’re traveling or have spotty internet
connection, you’ll be able to keep learning.
If you’re interested in learning more, you
can get 20% off an annual premium subscription
at Brilliant.org/microcosmos.
The people on the screen right now, these
people are our Patreon patrons.
They make it possible for us to do this show.
So, if you’re thankful for a nice pee episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos, they are the
people to thank.
If you would like to join them, you can go
to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.